let's end this gangbuster of an episode
with a trailer because you know me and
Disney plus I've nothing but great
things to say
there's a documentary about
fauci
um
when the Obama's got a Netflix deal and
now that I'm Harry and Megan have one
um it is becoming quite clear
that politicians are going to no longer
rely on the hacks in Hollywood and the
media to portray them in a flattering
light they are going to directly get
involved with how their legacies are
sculpted it's a pretty brilliant move
these people are directly going to get
involved in influence
public opinion so there is now a
documentary about fauci now whatever you
think of fauci running the gamut from
AIDS Hitler
to
second coming of of vaccine Christ
whatever you think about facts uh fauci
whatever you think about fouching this
is wildly unnecessary we are still in
the middle of a pandemic the resource is
devoted to making this film should not
have been let's watch the trailer okay
when I think about my dad growing up I
certainly think about that seriousness
but very few people get to see he's
funny weird and really playful God help
us
in 1981 HIV AIDS was evolving rapidly
and frighteningly there was anger at the
government's response when you got sick
you were gone fast
affecting you now yeah why I think he
was good I think you know from what I've
heard about
him
on the AIDS front I believe he was an
adult you know people are going to be
like he created it
you're a liar and I just
I but what I've heard from people that
work
in epidemiologies he was good on that
he's been a little bit of a klutz here
if if we want to be
really nice about it you'd call him a
klutz
um you if you wanted to be a meanie you
would call him a liar
and um
someone who has perhaps Twisted the
truth to protect people
um but Klutz would would certainly be
not wrong to call him but let's continue
this dressing
he also loves the spotlighting this
target my dad said we're gonna get
through this whole thing yeah
you do it because you care when you're
involved in a race to stop a horrible
disease
they always feel you're not doing things
quickly enough
[Music]
okay was morbid
it shows that he kind of failed like
massively well what was he supposed to
do you know completely like stop AIDS of
course
he's not supposed to do that
um you know I mean
I guess if you work in that business
like you're always gonna kind of fail
right you know
you know
he's an interesting guy he's been a
government
he's been the the pandemic guy forever
that's a weird dude
you know
the guy was like you know what gets me
up in the morning what disease you go
okay
stopping it or what it's like the people
that talk about poverty all the time
like do you really want it to end then
what would you do
I work at the center for Global poverty
okay and what would you like well
we'd like more Global poverty why well
that's kind of what we do
okay it's kind of with disease a little
bit Yeah Yeah like we don't want to get
rid of all the diseases
he's like we like to you know
we like a little bit of disease a little
bit makes everything work see that'd be
funny why doesn't Disney do that like do
an animated thing where fat she's like
having a little fun with gain of
function research you know he's like a
little bit makes everything work we need
and just needles like in the background
why can't we have a little fun where are
the talented people behind uh these
pictures we can do something with little
music
you know Laura who opened for me in
Boston works at Harvard and loves
fouching so I know that there's people
that love him and I my problem with him
is that he's an Italian an Italian and I
believe that we should be represented by
an Asian or a Jew in the medical field
or a Pakistani or someone from India I
don't trust a guy that looks like me
talking about health and I certainly
don't trust Mr meatball
but go check that out for yourself uh
what do they call Disney plus what is it
called it's Disney plus it's just called
fouchy they were shooting a doc this
this whole time I didn't know that
they're like the when we see Jake Paul
out and about and there's cameras
following him fauci had the same thing
but fauci's he's epidemiologist Jake
Paul that's what he is
fauci's epidemiology is Jake Paul you
can hate him you can love him but he
ain't going nowhere
that's what it is you could hate him you
could love him but that man is
determined to have his face Splash
there's a version of fauji that goes no
I don't want to do this
there's a version of him that goes I'm
busy
there's a version of him that goes I
don't think it's appropriate in the
middle of a pandemic that was supposedly
serious enough where we had to decimate
our entire economy I think it would be
odd to do like a a puff piece on me
why don't we wait a few years
but I guess not you just Dove right in
he goes here what time are you going to
be there nine
should I be a makeup I'll be in makeup
already
don't worry about it he's on the phone
he's like cancel the lab I got a thing
now I got all day this is the crew
showing up they're like we'll be quick
he's like no no we I blocked off a week
for this they go really
he goes yeah he goes I'm doing two dope
Queens later but right now I have all
the time to talk to you I'm doing my
favorite murder later I'm gonna tell
Karen kilgariff about the vaccine
enough with him